Ravens were once the most colorful birds
but they were too busy being unkind to
each other so they returned black but
Ravens really like to be together like
family thank you so much for coming to
our annual fourth of July party you mean
the world to us cheers to us and to
yours to come let me introduce you to my
Ravens now go get your victorious
bio-data cream
everybody this is my buddy Chat Chat
Chat Chat Chat make some birds fly alone
they're the ones that buy the highest
can see the most that be more beautiful
actually yes accountant Ravens usually
nest together for life no but sometimes
they visit with other Ravens I want to
divorce a woman who would like that
wouldn't she
I would this whole being friends with
the ex-husband thing it's weird real
nice to me because I think the truth
will hurt me more we're going to be best
friends you have to promise not to like
me
I had a dream I was as light as a bird
this parrot flying to the air and I
could see my home and my family